[موسيقى]
هذا ليس المكان الذي تتوقع أن ترى فيه سيارة
لامبورجيني سوبر كار، ولكن هذه
ليست سيارة لامبورجيني التي توقعها أي شخص على الإطلاق،
هذه هي لامبورجيني هوراكان سيراتو،
إنها تمامًا مثل سيارتك هوراكان العادية ولكن
الآن يمكنك القيام بذلك،
يمكنك القيادة على الطرق الوعرة
لم يطلبها أحد  من أجل ذلك، لكن لامبورجيني
صنعت واحدة على أي حال لأن بعض الأشخاص في
لامبورجيني اعتقدوا أنها صنعت واحدة
لأنفسهم وقرروا أنها كانت
ممتعة للغاية ويجب أن نقدمها للجميع، لذا
الآن إذا كان لديك ربع مليون
دولار، فيمكنك الحصول على محرك V10  Lamborghini
Supercar بإطارات للطرق الوعرة ونظام
تعليق ووضع الرالي حتى تتمكن من
أخذها على مسارات مثل هذه
[موسيقى]
قد تتساءل لماذا يحتاج أي شخص إلى
هذا بينما تمتلك Lamborghini بالفعل سيارة دفع رباعي،
الشيء الجيد هو أنه من الممتع
الانطلاق  -الطرق في سيارات الدفع الرباعي ولكن السير على
الطرق الوعرة أكثر متعة من شيء
ليس بالتأكيد سيارات الدفع الرباعي ولهذا
السبب تحتاج إلى هذه
السيارة لشخص يريد أن
تشعر سيارة الرالي من الثمانينيات أو التسعينيات بأقصى قدر من
الأداء المطلق والحصول على
الأوساخ  تنسيق
[موسيقى]
وقيادة سيارة لامبورغيني مقابل مجموعة من
الأوساخ هو أمر ممتع بقدر ما
يبدو أن هناك
مقايضات بالطبع
تفتقر هوراكان سيرادو إلى وضع
كورسا أو قيادة المسار القوي للغاية الذي
تحصل عليه في الطرز الأخرى لأنها
إطارات و  التعليق قادر على تقديم
أداء مثالي على المسار بشكل
جيد معي، ولا يزال بإمكانه التعامل مع
المنحنيات عالية السرعة بشكل جيد ومع
أكثر من 600 حصان، فإنه لا يزال
سريعًا جدًا، تم رفع التعليق قليلاً
للحصول على خلوص أرضي إضافي وتتيح مشاعل الرفارف الكبيرة هذه مساحة
لهؤلاء
خصيصًا  صنعت إطارات قابلة للتشغيل مع مداس
للطرق الوعرة بالمناسبة هوراكان
سيراتو بسعر يبدأ من حوالي 270
ألف دولار، وهي أيضًا آخر سيارة
لامبورغيني سوبركار تعمل بالبنزين تمامًا
بعد ذلك، وستكون جميع نماذج لامبورغيني المستقبلية
هجينة أو كهربائية.
لا تبالغ في المبالغة، يمكنك أن
تتوقع أن تصبح هذه السيارة ذات يوم قابلة للتحصيل بشكل كبير
[موسيقى]